all right so this is the more where we
get the backstory kind of love BMO which
I never even thought of backstory BMO
again that's one of the cool things
about this show is like you just don't
you don't think about this stuff but
it's like Oh added bonus like that's
great
so all right so we got BMO accidentally
delete some files which I very much
relate to I've done that way too often
yes including a V log or two so I very
much relate to that and so she has to go
to what's the name of the place the mo
Factory my mo Factory yes
yes in the badlands and to get herself
fixed so Finn and Jake taker but they
can't allow anything that's not ammo
pretty much
so they disguise themselves as Mo's I
just love that the combos and they speak
air then these guards are chasing them
and everything and at the very end they
come across what seems to be a human at
least he's wearing human skin
horrified that who is moe and he's
really really always coughing and stuff
but he is technically like BMO's poop
yep NZ put it not as Graham not grant
poop just poop and uh shows all the
robots that he's made it's all her
brothers and sisters and they're like
that tiny and she says hi and people has
a family and it's adorable
it's so cute um and yeah they're just
guys stops there um I don't think
they're all really tiny ones it's just a
time yeah I think that's what it was
yeah because if you look when they're
looking at the map there's that huge
then there's a huge tunnel okay so that
does this go okay yeah yeah okay um but
nevertheless they're still so cute um
and the whole now like you know there's
want to say like qmo and JMO one was
just like heart yeah like very feminine
way so um yeah is
it was a fun episode I think it like it
started off a little slow like everyone
wants a lot one female would glitch like
eight times
certainly okay let's get that going um
but as soon as the other like security
guards came in and they had that fun
little chase yeah you know till it's
alright turn corkscrew family you know
that remind me a lot temple do Oh
rollercoaster think it's what a few
things are really enjoying that movie
that's the one main thing that always
took me out of it
know what the devil do murders short
round Osho I hate short oh yeah like a
rag doll yeah yeah he's Stretch
Armstrong sorry but but anyway yeah so
fun though chase and yeah we get to find
out a little bit about her history which
is pretty cool and it's just a v-mail
episode I love BMO episodes I think you
know she's just freaking adorable we
were talking about if they made BMO
cookies we would totally buy them I
would eat them she would not because do
cute vivos do cute so uh uh I like that
I'm actually more fascinated on you know
like human mo you know the fact that
this is another human and the fact that
he has this worker that obviously treats
him horribly always throws him to the
ground
oh yeah he's not aware of it but I mean
so me slamming up to the ground but this
guy's got to be like a bajillion or
something I mean you saw old and like
you can see his bones and everything and
yeah he's always being slant to the
ground so said that was starting over a
thousand years ago yeah and again it was
kind of eating a factory of where these
machines were built but again it's all
destroyed and everything so oh I know
the other thing I'll bring up is the I
love when the security guards come big
blast and they think they're gone yeah
and then usually you cut to whatever
Finn and Jake trying to figure out
another way you're trying to figure out
something but you just kind of followed
them for oh yeah and you don't know
where Finn and Jake are and you just see
them like go on the end the vending
machines and they vending machines
clearly meant for humans and yet they
still try to eat and drink them but they
cancel because up against the other yeah
I mean that was great cuz I was seeing
the vending machine I'm like well no how
does this work is it like some sort of
mofooskay-heeko
I thought that was very funny it was a
nice like a nice little detour as well
just keeping away from the heroes for
this moment just to hear about these you
know security guards normal wives so no
I like that that was a lot of fun that
is probably one of my favorite parts of
the whole episode watching them and it's
just such a simple word but just the way
they kept repeating and it was kind of
funny it reminds me of myself sometimes
I get like on a little kick and I'll
like pick a word that's my new favorite
word and they're just like they're Lagoo
yeah what a goof this is like it's a
silly word it's a simple word but I'm
like okay so many favorite words I use
that word I love that where I call my
wife and goof all the way they were
having this conversation I just loved it
a lot and yeah it's got lots of cute and
and I love cute good cuz the whole
family that whole thing when you look
down you see I'm like doing the jump
rope and stuff it's like watering their
flowers on the balcony
how that there has to be toys on these
things or like pillows or something I
mean it's like they're they're
practically made for that I will point
until they start doing it yeah that's
unless it goes over 20 which could be
the new Pokemon type thing
baby most complete all the BMO's pokemon
collect all the Mo's pokum oh oh
no poke a bow please tell him no that is
pretty hard over there don't encourage
him seriously what do you think Jason
though it's not this point I just love
at the beginning
BMO getting high yeah that was weird I
didn't know if it was getting higher
watching porn drunk he'll think about it
he's dragging stuff tossing it in his in
his delete folder in his recycle bin and
he's like and even as he's out and he's
like falls over like he's drunk
I was gonna say did we see what those
files were I saw something with Finn and
there are they just not important
finally what the files were I think it
matters that he was getting some sort of
like giving reference oh yeah I didn't
even think about that it's like I saw
she was care having fun with it but I
never thought about what it was I was
just like oh like cleaning up his farm
Oh chop which is terrible to be much
Cubs awesome
but like clearly she doesn't matter the
BMO Champion no no like I love how he
was getting drunk and wasted off doing
that and then of course Nokia because
he's taking like chunks and deleting him
and he deletes his command
you know stuff which is incredibly
important so therefore it's like ah crap
I loved that finish fact and what I mean
by that is notice Finn has always been
kind of like straight once he lifts up
his shirts yeah he's got some love
handles I love that and he's not fat but
yeah he's generally has love handles
like he's putting on a little bit of
weight and I think that's kind of neat
that he's not just aging vocally or
anything he's actually missing elements
you know G I think that's kind of cool
and maybe it maybe it's not fat maybe
he's just filling out maybe their muscle
handles well
I also love the stuff attached to mo get
the heart through the little ones yeah
those were great I thought that was cool
um I loved the hand was gee mo it's like
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm not able to
answer that question and wait a minute
you're not able to ask that question
oh and J stream guy and Jake's like what
question is like no no no that's fun and
I do agree I think the guards doing
their little just discussion was great
yeah those gooks ask you how we're doing
what do you mean what I'm doing goofs
asking questions well you say it just so
came out of nowhere like you know they
think they're gone they have a little
bit of a routine you know do we really
vaporize them a little turn around okay
whatever usually that's where it would
end and you see MJ do something else or
figure something out you just keep
following them so yeah that was a very
nice change of pace
what I also liked two things one is when
they're falling under like boom snail
boom there's me more pork boom another
room boom
I just thought that was great before
yeah I do like magic go through the Bema
form like you know crap and of course
when Finn runs up research digging Biman
jamming him against the wall yeah
where's the B port that was funny
pretty funny so yeah I liked it was fun
yeah no definitely a fun episode and it
makes me think back to the very first
Segway I ever did what was the first
thing more you said be more something
this is be more BMO I am I was so
confused and now I'm even more confused
yeah why isn't he called keep sheep why
isn't she called emo why is it it's
called yeah because if it's on me maybe
there is a name oh we just haven't seen
a mo yet no there was a port for email
yeah but have we seen a mo in physical
form yet well but BMO is so great why
would you no no I'm just curious what
was before BMO it doesn't matter because
he made BMO too
be more I know but now I'm just here's
what the first one is a failure
obviously but women have to see the feel
you owe me for the second one to
suddenly be this great big success it's
like what was the first one even if it
was a failure I am intrigued I would
like to see a bow talking about it early
I got too much time of it that's all
okay that's all excited by the thing
about a bow has this that that's where I
draw the line
oh I just have a feeling that somewhere
in that tunnel of Moe's was probably a
male maybe oh gosh I want scene episode
with an AVO let's get let's get mo going
alright if we saw a mo fans find that
snippet of wherever he or she was showed
and show it to me because I want to see
my aim I want to know all this first
before BMO I'm just into the creative
process fascinates me shut up you goof